und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
seit heute Nachmittag laufen die
Evakuierungsaktionen für deutsche und
andere ausländische Staatsbürger aus
Sudan die erste Bundeswehrmaschine
landete dort gegen 16 Uhr nach Angaben
des Krisenstabs im Auswärtigen Amt
arbeiten bei dieser riskantenmission
Deutsche und Franzosen eng zusammen und
Menschen zu einem Flughafen außerhalb
der Stadt zu bringen die Bundeswehr ist
mit Soldaten in cartoum unter anderem
mit Eliteeinheiten der Division schnelle
Kräfte und dem KSK die darauf
spezialisiert sind genau da reinzugehen
wo Zivilisten rausgeholt werden sollen
Andreas
es ist riskant sich auf den Weg zu
machen aber es ist noch riskanter zu
bleiben im hier so Gespenster stillen
kartum das plötzlich so gefährlichsten
Hauptstadt der Welt wurde die Europäer
die fliehen wurden von ihren Botschaften
gebeten das Risiko ab Kollegen
gegebenenfalls eine andere Route zu
wählen nur wenig Gepäck mitzunehmen und
keine Haustiere die ungefähr noch 300
deutschen im Sudan bekamen am Morgen das
Signal aus der Botschaft sich jetzt zu
einem Sammelpunkt zu begeben Deutschland
evakuiert zur selben Zeit und in enger
Zusammenarbeit mit Frankreich weil am
Hauptstadtflughafen trotz Waffenruhe
gekämpft wird steuert der Konvoi ein
Flugfeld in der Umgebung an Name und
Standort sollen vertraulich bleiben seit
Tagen haben Dutzende Staaten auf einen
Waffenstillstand gewartet der stabil
genug ist um die Evakuierung zu wagen
das niederländische Militär unterlegt
diese vorbereitungsbilder sogar mit
Musik
Speicher einer Heilung wir stehen in den
stadtlöchern und warten darauf dass sich
das Zeitfenster öffnet um die
Operationen der gefährlichen Lage im
Sudan auszuführen
Deutschland startet seine
evakuierungsmission aus Jordanien vom
Luftwaffenstützpunkt all asrack aus sind
am Nachmittag zwei A400M in der Nähe von
cartoum gelandet das Ziel so viele
Deutsche wie möglich Ausfliegen
Fallschirmjäger und KSK-Soldaten sind am
Einsatz beteiligt dass der
Waffenstillstand hält glaubt man in den
westlichen Hauptstädten nicht das heißt
wer heute woanders als in Karton ist
wird es nicht zu den Flugzeugen schaffen
diesen Flüchtlingen bleibt nur der Weg
über Land hunderte haben sich bereits
auf den Weg gemacht eilig werden von
Europas Verteidigungsministerien Schiffe
nach Port Sudan befohlen
zurückbleiben 2,6 Millionen soldanesen
allein in Karton für die es keine
Evakuierungspläne gibt
das beste dass wir tun können um Briten
zu schützen und jeden im Sudan ist die
generelle die in diesen Konflikt
verwickelt Prozent zu drängen ihn zu
beenden und das wird unsere Priorität
sein
noch hält in Berlin der Krisenstab den
Atem an noch ist kein Kommentar zu hören
noch ist das Parlament nicht befasst
noch das Mandat nicht beschlossen noch
ist Gefahr im Verzug
ja und Bilder gibt es von dieser
eierkurierungsaktion nachvollziehbarer
Weise bislang auch praktisch keine
theo-kolbers hört man denn in Berlin
überhaupt über den bisherigen Verlauf
nun um mit dem Positiven zu Beginn der
erste deutsche evakuierungsflug ist am
Abend offensichtlich aus dem Sudan
gestartet das wurde hier in Berlin der
dpa bestätigt die im Einsatz
befindlichen Militärmaschinen A400M
bieten in der Regel Platz für 14
Passagiere im Notfall auch bis 200
insgesamt sollen etwas ja über 300
deutsche ausgeflogen werden also
Botschaftsmitarbeiter Entwicklungshelfer
Geschäftsleute der zweite Airbus ist
ebenfalls vor Ort viele im Sudan lebende
Ausländer wollten offensichtlich auch
nicht auf die Luft Evakuierung warten
und versuchen über Land aus dem Sudan zu
fliehen gestern ist es vielen saudischen
Bürgern gelungen die dann in Portugal
800 km von der Haupt entfernt von einem
Kriegsschiff an Bord genommen worden
ist ja ein erster Versuch am Mittwoch
abgebrochen worden von deutscher Seite
die eigenen Staatsbürger rauszuholen
ja die Zusicherung auf freies Geleit bzw
Waffenruhe die hatte ist zunächst auch
beim ersten Versuch gegeben da die
Kämpfe aber dennoch anhielten wurde die
deutsche Aktion dann am Mittwoch
gestoppt jetzt geht man hier in Berlin
aktuell davon aus dass die Feuerpause
hoffentlich noch bis morgen Mittag oder
Abend hält das wäre dann das Ende der
dreitägigen Feiertage nach dem Ramadan
insgesamt wird die Lage aber als sehr
gefährlich bewertet und die Rhetorik
beiderseiten lässt neue Kämpfer erwarten
die Bundeswehr stellt sich jedenfalls
auch auf sogenannte robustere
Evakuierung einem notfalls deutsche auch
mit Waffengewalt aus dem Sudan zu retten
es wurden zahlreiche Kräfte nach
Jordanien verlegt insgesamt seinen rund
1000 Soldaten beteiligt unter anderem
wie eben gehört auch falsche Jäger und
KSK aber insgesamt scheint man in Berlin
von der Eskalationen so da ja doch
überrascht worden zu sein
ja wobei man sagen muss das ging
allerdings auch vielen anderen
Regierungen so die Lage so heißt es hier
habe sich plötzlich entwickelt nachdem
die Eingliederung der mächtigen
rsf-milizen die regulären Streitkräfte
gescheitert sei ein solcher
Bundeswehreinsatz übrigens wie der jetzt
laufende darf eigentlich nicht ohne
Bundestagsmandat erfolgen dieses Mandat
muss jetzt aufgrund der Dringlichkeit im
Nachhinein erteilt werden und es soll
offensichtlich schnellstmöglich durchs
Kabinett und dann auch durchs Parlament
danke schön Theo für diese Information
es war einer der schwierigsten
tarifkonflikte seit langer Zeit Monate
lang haben sich bunt und Kommunen mit
den Gewerkschaften Verdi und Beamtenbund
gestritten bis zur Schlichtung dass die
nun erfolgreich war sorgt erstmal für
Erleichterung die öffentlichen
Arbeitgeber klagen aber wie teuer dieser
Kompromiss sie zu stehen kommt das hilft
den Gewerkschaften das Ergebnis als
Erfolg zu feiern auch darum ging es ja
in diesem Konflikt angesichts ihres
Mitgliederschwunds brauchten die
Gewerkschaften einen harter kämpften
Erfolg und wieder attraktiver zu sein
was aber nicht heißt dass ihre
Mitglieder jetzt auch alle zufrieden
sind wie Katrin Lindners Bericht
deutlich wird
Krankenschwester Roberta marche tot in
Hamburg auf dem Weg von der Frühschicht
nach Hause für sie kommt die Erhöhung
des Entgeltes nächstes Jahr zu spät und
es ist ja auch zu wenig also ich bin
echt enttäuscht und frustriert ich
arbeite in der Pflege wir waren hier
immer systemrelevant in der ganzen
Pandemie da habe ich mir jetzt auch
einfach mehr erwartet zusammen mit
Erzieherin Katharina doll organisierte
sie in den vergangenen Monaten
arbeitsstreiks auch sie hat sich mehr
erhofft wir haben einfach für mehr
gekämpft wir wollten 500 €. wir wollten
10,5% auf 12 Monate und jetzt ist die
Situation die dass auf 12 Monate
eigentlich unsere Löhne eingefroren
werden Mitternacht haben die
Verhandlungspartner ihr Ergebnis bekannt
gegeben ein Inflationsausgleich von 3000
€ ab März 2024 200 € mehr lohnen danach
eine Steigerung um 5,5% mindestens 340 €
bei einer Laufzeit von 24 Monaten die
Gewerkschaften wurden von den
Arbeitgebern statt Inflationsausgleich
eine höhere Steigerung der Gehälter in
den unteren Einkommensgruppen betonen
aber jetzt das ist die größte
Tarifsteigerung in der
Nachkriegsgeschichte im öffentlichen
Dienst dann ist es glaube ich so dass
bei aller auch Komplexität der Lösung
die sich manchmal nicht ganz leicht
erschließt deutlich wird dass das hier
eine nachhaltige Verbesserung der
Einkommenssituation ist wir haben einen
guten und fairen Tarifabschluss für die
mehr als 2,5 Millionen Beschäftigte für
von Bund und Kommunen getroffen
Göttingen hier müssen sie wegen
Personalmangel und sehr hohen
Krankenstand einen abgesteckten Fahrplan
fahren weil Personal nicht zu finden ist
auf Gehaltssteigerungen rückwirkend zum
ersten Januar haben sie gesetzt
Einmalzahlungen bringen keine
Rentenpunkte und zählen nicht beim
Krankengeld es gibt eine einmalige
Zahlung und bei vielen Kollegen verpufft
die also das ist ja eine Zahlung die da
Arbeitgeber freiwillig leisten könnte
können auf den Lohn drauf und deshalb
finde ich das nicht gerechtfertigt dass
man die zur Lohnrunde mit einbezieht
Eichwalde bei Berlin was kann sich die
6000 Einwohnergemeinde dieses Jahr noch
leisten die Kämmerin heute beim Prüfen
ihrer Planungen neben höheren
Personalausgaben muss sie auch immer
mehr Aufgaben stemmen
sei es die Digitalisierung sei es
geflüchteten sei es aber auch die
kita-bedarfe oder die Grundschule und da
ist wirklich wo ich mir wünsche dass uns
der Bund und das Land tatsächlich mehr
unterstützt bis zum 12 Mai will die
Gewerkschaft Verdi ihre Mitglieder über
die Einigung abstimmen lassen
die Protestgruppe letzte Generation hat
ja angekündigt Berlin ab morgen zum
Stillstand zu bringen und darf gespannt
sein ob Berliner Autofahrer und
Fahrerinnen den Unterschied zu normalen
Berliner stautagen überhaupt merken
werden der Ärger ist aber jetzt schon
groß dafür reichte schon die Ankündigung
und das ist ja auch das
Alleinstellungsmerkmal gewissermaßen
dieser Gruppe die sucht nicht nach
Sympathie sondern nach Aufregung sie
blockiert nicht wie früher z.B die Anti
akw-bewegung Castor Transporte und
ähnliches sondern stört den Alltag vor
allem den Alltag von Autofahrern trifft
damit einen Nerv
ob das der Sache hilft ist in der
klimaschutzbewegung umstritten dazu
gleich noch ein Gespräch doch zunächst
berichtet Henriette de Maizière aus
Berlin
ist es die Ruhe vor dem Sturm die letzte
Generation wie sie sich selber nennen
wollen ab morgen die Hauptstadt
lahmlegen Straßenblockaden Provokationen
ziviler Ungehorsam immer in der Hoffnung
Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren die Politik
zum Handeln zu zwingen mich treibt aber
natürlich auch die Verzweiflung darüber
an dass die Verantwortlichen gerade in
der Politik nicht die Verantwortung
übernehmen dass sie uns damit alleine
lassen und uns weiter Richtung Abgrund
in die Klimakrise stoßen heute
Solidaritätskundgebung am Brandenburger
Tor für eine streitbare Bewegung gerade
weil es zu polarisiert stelle ich immer
wieder fest dass unheimlich viele
Gespräche möglich sind mit Menschen über
mit denen ich sonst nie über
Klimapolitik ins Gespräch kommen würde
sehr weit unten im Vergleich zu den
Auswirkungen des Klimawandels bereits
gestern hatten die AktivistInnen
Luxusleben im Berliner Westen mit Farbe
attackiert ihre These reiche Menschen
sind in ungleich höherem Maße für den
CO2 Ausstoß verantwortlich
die Proteste das Thema Klimaschutz und
die Konsequenzen daraus offenbar kein
gewinnerthema mehr laut ZDF
Politbarometer lehnt eine große Mehrheit
von 82%
illegale Aktionen wie die Blockade von
Autobahnen ab jede zweite Person
fürchtet für sich starke oder sehr
starke finanzielle Belastung durch den
Klimaschutz
die Grünen scheinen beim Thema
Klimaschutz in die Defensive gekommen
distanzieren sich im Interview bei
Berlin direkt vom radikalen klimaprotest
ich halte es nicht für produktiv wenn am
Ende eines Protestes mehr um die
Protestform als über den Inhalt geredet
wird das ist komplett klar wir sehen
alle die Klimakrise ist real,-
Protest gefällt oder nicht gefällt wir
müssen mehr tun mehr tun darauf hatte
die letzte Generation ihre Hoffnung
gerade beim grünen Teil der Ampel gelegt
ein nüchterung
und das ist ein Muster was wir auch ein
anderer Stelle schon gesehen haben dass
gerade Menschen die große Erwartungen
Regierungen stellen wenn das nicht
passiert ist es durchaus gefährlich für
Parteien bis hin zur Möglichkeit das
neue Parteien entstehen die
angekündigten Proteste der letzten
Generation der drohende Stillstand in
der Hauptstadt er bewegt die Gemüter was
darf Protest
Felix Anderl ist uns zugeschaltet
Professor für konfliktforschungen der
Universität Marburg und sein
Forschungsschwerpunkt liegt auf den
sozialen Bewegungen und
Protestbewegungen der Professor an der
guten Abend
guten Abend Frauke wenn man sich die
letzte Generation als Gruppe anguckt
also entstanden bei einem bei einem
Hungerstreik die Mitglieder die gehen
relativ hohe Risiken ein auch für ihre
körperliche Unversehrtheit das Risiko
ins Gefängnis zu gehen die radikal ist
diese Gruppierung wie schätzen Sie das
ein
ja das Paradox ja in der letzten
Generation ist dass ihre Forderungen ja
eigentlich beinahe banal sind also
überhaupt nicht radikal 9 € Ticket
Tempolimit ein Bürger in rat das ist
eigentlich alles gar nicht so
weitreichend das könnte man mit dem ins
doing kommen was Herr Scholz angekündigt
hat eigentlich gut vereinen aber ihre
Protestformen sind eben doch relativ
radikal und sie sind sehr überzeugt von
ihren Inhalten und sind bereit dafür
auch große Risiken einzugehen und ich
glaube das führt auch ein bisschen zu
Verwirrung in der Analyse von dieser
Bewegung es wird ja auch zu Kritik also
die Grünen sagen Mensch das wird jetzt
mehr über die Protest Form geredet als
über das worum es eigentlich geht
ähnliches sollte man vom Fridays for
future oder vom world life fand also die
Gruppe setzt sich auf dem Vorwurf aus
viel Raum zu machen aber damit dann
eigentlich wenig zu erreichen
genau und da gibt es innerhalb der
Bewegung mittlerweile auch eine große
Diskussion
es gibt glaube ich einen Konsens darüber
dass die Bewegung sehr erfolgreich darin
war die Themen auf die Tagesordnung zu
bringen also innerhalb von wenigen
Jahren wurde das Klimathema immer
salonfähiger immer wichtiger und jetzt
ist eben die Frage wie geht es weiter
und da gibt es grob gesagt mal ganz
banal gesprochen zwei grobe Richtungen
schockieren oder überzeugen und auch in
der Protesten Bewegungsforschung gibt es
ja mittlerweile relativ gute Studien
dazu wie diese verschiedenen
Protestformen eben wirken es gibt
Studien dazu dass die radikalen
Protestformen insgesamt eher abgelehnt
werden von der Gesamtbevölkerung also
dass sie die Zustimmungswerte der
Bewegung eher negativ beeinflussen auf
der anderen Seite gibt es aber auch
Studien dazu das ist so ein sogenannten
radikalen flankeneffekt gibt das heißt
die Moder datenteile der Bewegung
profitieren eigentlich davon wenn die
radikalen delezimiert werden weil die
moderaten sich dann als die vernünftigen
dastehen können und das kann man auf die
Klimabewegung eigentlich ganz gut
anwenden wo Fridays for future so ein
bisschen die moderate Flanke ist und die
letzte Generationen eben die eher
radikalere aber in welchem Verhältnis
stehen diese Gruppierungen zueinander
droht da auch eine Spaltung dieser
klimaschutzbewegung
also ganz prinzipiell wäre es nicht
überraschend weil die meisten Bewegungen
irgendwann miteinander im Clint fliegen
und sich oft auch Spalten die
Klimabewegung war bisher eigentlich
ziemlich gut darin beisammen zu bleiben
es gibt einige protestforscher manche
Kollegen von mir die sagen deine
Spaltung vorher und es gibt das muss man
zugeben auch zunehmend knarzt innerhalb
der Bewegung aber ich würde nicht sagen
dass das notwendigerweise passiert also
eine erfolgreiche Bewegung ist
eigentlich meistens dann gegeben wenn es
eine moderate Flanke gibt und eine
radikale und die irgendwie in der Lage
sind trotzdem an einem Strang zu sehen
und in der Klimabewegung würde ich sagen
der
Stress den innerhalb gibt der ist
eigentlich nicht inhaltlich sondern nur
taktisch begründet also über die
Klimaziele sind sich die
bewegungsakteure eigentlich einig sie
sind sich auch darüber einig dass eine
radikale Veränderung der Politik folgen
muss sie sind sich nur nicht darüber
einig wie man dahin kommt und deswegen
denke ich eigentlich dass die
Voraussetzungen dafür gegeben sind dass
Bewegung auch langfristig mit so einer
inside outside Strategie ganz gute
Erfolge erzielen kann Herr andern danke
für die Analyse und die Einschätzung
herzlichen Dank
das Gespräch haben wir für eine Stunde
geführt stillstand gibt es in Berlin
nicht nur im Verkehr ob eine große
Koalition da mehr bewegt bekommt wird
man sehen jedenfalls wissen wir seit
heute Nachmittag das ist die wohl geben
wird die große Koalition heißt die
Berliner SPD-Mitglieder haben sich für
den ausgehandelten Koalitionsvertrag
ausgesprochen bei
54,3% lag die Zustimmung nach Angaben
der Landesvorsitzenden gifhall CDU und
SPD hatten ihren Koalitionsvertrag
Anfang April vorgestellt und wenn nun
morgen bei der CDU der Parteitag
ebenfalls grünes Licht gibt ist der Weg
für die Koalitionsregierung frei und der
CDU Landesvorsitzende Wegner könnte
schon am Donnerstag zum Regierenden
Bürgermeister gewählt werden
bundesinnenministerin Faser SPD hat
Obergrenzen für eine Aufnahme
geflüchteter in Deutschland erneut
abgelehnt sie sei aber sehr aktiv auch
auf europäische Ebene was die Frage der
Ordnung Steuerung Begrenzung betreffend
sagte sie im ZDF heute Interview
Höchstgrenzen zu definieren wenn Krieg
in der Ukraine ist glaube sie könne man
im Moment nicht verlangen
der sächsische Ministerpräsident
Kretschmer CDU sagte der Bild am Sonntag
zum Thema Migration die Bundesregierung
müsse beim nächsten Treffen am 10 Mai
Lösungen für die Länder und Kommunen
präsentieren es gehe nicht allein ums
Geld sondern darum dass die Anzahl der
Menschen die zu uns kommt reduziert
werden müssen freiwillige
Aufnahmeprogramme wie etwa für
ortskräfte aus Afghanistan müssten
sofort gestoppt werden
nach der Messerattacke in einem
Duisburger Fitnessstudio vor fünf Tagen
hat die Polizei den mutmaßlichen Täter
festgenommen es soll sich um einen
26-jährigen Syrer Handeln ihm wird
vorgeworfen am Dienstagabend vier
Menschen mit einer Stichwaffe schwer
verletzt zu haben ein 21-jähriger ist
weiterhin in Lebensgefahr über das Motiv
des Angreifers ist noch nichts bekannt
nah Hannover sind bei einem Unfall an
einem Bahnübergang drei Menschen ums
Leben gekommen Ihr Fahrzeug wurde von
einem Regionalzug erfasst als sie am
frühen Morgen die Gleise trotz
geschlossener Halbschranke und rotem
Signal überqueren wollten der Pkw wurde
mehrere hundert Meter mitgeschleift
einer der Zugpassagiere wurde durch die
Bremsung leicht verletzt im Bahnverkehr
kam es über mehrere Stunden zu
Verspätungen und Zug Ausfällen
Beobachter des ukrainerkrieges melden
über Social Media dass es ukrainischen
Einheiten gelungen sei bei herson den
Fluss zu überqueren strategische wäre
das wichtig und schon wird gemunkelt ob
das ein Vorbote der ukrainischen
Frühjahrsoffensive sein wie die aussehen
wird wann sie beginnt und wo das Wissen
aber wohl nur sehr wenige Personen in
der Ukraine aber alle warten darauf auf
Prognosen von außen sollte man dabei
aber wohl eher nicht setzen es wird ja
zum Beispiel auch seit Monaten gesagt
dass die Ukraine bachmut nicht halten
können und es aufgeben sollten
doch bachmut wird weitergehalten dafür
sorgt unter anderem jene Panzer Einheit
die unsere Reporter daran begleitet hat
wir fahren zu einer taktischen
panzereinheit stationiert nur wenige
Kilometer hinter der ukrainischen
kontaktlinie bei bachmut immer
einsatzbereit die Soldaten schlafen in
einfachen Datschen durchschnittlich zwei
bis sechs Kämpfer in einem Haus so kann
ein russischer Artillerie Angriff nicht
die ganze Einheit treffen
wir sind nicht weit weg von der
Frontlinie entfernt es ist ein Ort von
dem wir schnell agieren können wenn der
Befehl für einen Einsatz kommt
seit sechs Monaten kämpft die Einheit
schon um bachmut ruhige Tage wie heute
waren selten die Gefahr zu sterben
schwebt immer über ihn
es ist nur natürlich wenn du Angst hast
es bedeutet Dein Körper hat diese
spezielle Situation adaptiert du darfst
nicht an schlimme Dinge denken mache
einfach deinen Job
den Weg von den Schlafplätzen zu den
Positionen der Panzer müssen wir zu Fuß
zurücklegen vorbei an zerstörten Häusern
sie machen deutlich dass die russische
Artillerie hier ukrainische Stellungen
vermutet
der Boden sieht mir hier ist noch
vollkommen durchdrängt matschig es ist
nur immer noch nicht die beste Zeit für
eine große Offensive
es geht weiter zu unserer Garage wie
Offizier Kosmos den Zielort
wir haben jetzt dicke Wolken sie
schützen uns
es ist der versteckte Stützpunkt der
panzereinheit ihre Aufgabe ist es den
Versorgungsweg in das umkämpfte bachmut
offen zu halten
wir sind die Lebensversicherung wir
operieren in Frontabschnitten die unser
Oberkommando festlegt wir schlagen
feindliche Durchbrüche zurück und werden
die Russen nicht die Straße nach bachmut
abschneiden lassen
dies machen sie mit alten Panzern aus
der Sowjet Zeit moderne Leoparden würden
die Kampfkraft der Einheit enorm erhöhen
allein schon wegen der Nachtsichttechnik
mit eigenen Augen gesehen hat Kapitän
aber noch keinen deutschen Panzer
diese Technik ist alt ich habe mein
Studium an der Militärakademie 1992
abgeschlossen und ich vermute ich habe
genau auf solchen Panzern gelernt so
ohne technischen Fortschritt können wir
zwar auch gewinnen aber es wird viele
Leben unserer Soldaten Kosten
und dem Zuge der angekündigten große
Offensive könnten noch weitere Aufgaben
auf die Einheit hinzukommen
jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz mit dem Sport zunächst zur
Fußball-Bundesliga mit drei Spielen und
diesen Ergebnissen Freiburg Schalke 4:0
bei der Leverkusen RB Leipzig 2:0 und
Borussia Mönchengladbach Union Berlin 0
zu 1
der Deutsche Meistertitel im Eishockey
der Männer geht nach München die
Entscheidung brachte das fünfte Playoff
Spiel dass die Münchner gegen Ingolstadt
mit 3:1 gewonnen es war ein hartes Stück
Arbeit für die Münchner ehe ihr vierter
Meistertitel feststand Ingolstadt Macht
zu wenig aus Überzahlspiel die Münchner
weitaus effektiver das 2:1 durch Andreas
Eder 8 Minuten vor Schluss bringt den
EHC auf die Siegerstraße Ingolstadt
versucht alles
Opfer den Torwart für einen weiteren
Feldspieler für wareka ist das
freigeräumte Tor die Einladung zum 3:1
und damit zum vierten Sieg in der
Finalserie München nach 5 Jahren wieder
die deutsche Hochburg im Eishockey
fehlt noch unser sonnentägliche Ausblick
auf die nächste Woche Carolina Freitag
hat da für uns in den Terminkalender
geschaut
[Musik]
seit Beginn der Tarifverhandlungen Ende
Februar haben sich die Bahn Arbeitgeber
und die Bahngewerkschaft EVG kaum
annähern können mit zwei bundesweiten
Streiktagen hat die Gewerkschaft
versucht den Druck zu erhöhen kommt es
bald zur Einigung ab Dienstag wird
wieder verhandelt
drei Jahre nach dem Holocaust Gründen
die Juden ihren eigenen Stadt Israel die
Erklärung verlesen von David bengorion
im Jahr 1948
75 Jahre später blickt Israel auf eine
wechselvolle Geschichte
Dauerkonflikt mit den Palästinensern
wirtschaftlicher Aufschwung militärische
Dominanz ihnen politische Krisen am
Mittwoch wird vielerorts gefeiert aber
womöglich auch wieder demonstriert die
Leipziger Buchmesse feiert ihr Comeback
nach drei Jahren Zwangspause und einer
Debatte über die Zukunft der Messe neue
Formate sollen viele Besucher anlocken
das Land ist Österreich Bereich am
Mittwochabend wird die Branchenschau
offiziell eröffnet ab Donnerstag werden
die Hallen für das Publikum offenstehen
im Ausland lebende Türkinnen und Türken
werden von Donnerstag an ihre Stimmen
für die parlaments- und
Präsidentenwahlen in der Türkei abgeben
können in Deutschland leben knapp 1,5
Millionen Wahlberechtigte 2018 stimmten
sie mit großer Mehrheit für Präsident
Erdogan das Oppositionsbündnis rund um
Herausforderer
morgen sind im Nordwesten und Westen die
Wolken meist dicht und des regnet auch
mal länger sonst gibt es ein Mix aus
Sonne und Wolken mit nur einzelnen
Schauern bei einem sehr lebhaften
Westwind werden 9 bis 17 Grad erreicht
die weiteren Aussichten bis Mittwoch
bleibt es bei diesem kühlen und
wechselhaften Wetter am Donnerstag gibt
es dann mehr Sonne und es wird mit 10
bis 17 Grad auch wieder wärmer
morgen Abend erwarten Sie hier Christian
Sievers und Hanna Zimmermann
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]